>> Bill: SEVERAL HEADLINES AT
ONE TIME.
THE PRESIDENT GOING TO PHOENIX,
ARIZONA.
AIR FORCE ONE IS NOW OPEN.
MEANWHILE, FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT HEADLINES
RIGHT NOW.
JOHN ROBERTS FROM THE NORTH
LAWN.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THE
TASK FORCE APPARENTLY WINDING
DOWN.
JOHN, WHAT DID YOU FIND OUT
ABOUT THIS?
>> YOU SAW THE MEETING AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT’S OFFICE JUST A
SHORT TIME AGO.
THE HHS SECRETARY, DR. STEPHEN
HAHN, WHO IS THE FDA
COMMISSIONER.
HHS, WHO IS IN CHARGE WITH
GETTING A LOT OF EQUIPMENT WHERE
IT’S SUPPOSED TO BE.
STEPHEN, WHO IS THE
ADMINISTRATOR FOR MEDICARE,
MEDICAID SERVICES, WAS THERE AS
WELL.
THE BIG HEADLINE DIDN’T COME OUT
OF THE BRIEFING.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THAT
DEVELOPMENT OF THE MANHATTAN
PROJECT.
THEY ARE SAYING IT COULD
POSSIBLY BE DONE.
THE HEADLINE POPPED AND WE ASKED
THE VICE PRESIDENT ABOUT IT
REGARDING THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE WINDING DOWN SOMETIME
WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH.
THE PRESIDENT DID CONFIRM THAT
THEY’VE BEEN HAVING
PRELIMINARY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THAT.
HE HOPES SOMETIME AROUND
MEMORIAL DAY OR MAYBE THE
BEGINNING OF JUNE THEY COULD
BEGIN TO WIND DOWN THE
TASK FORCE
TASK FORCE AND HAND THE WORK
THAT THE TASK FORCE WAS DOING
OVER THE VARIOUS AGENCIES.
FEMA, HHS WOULD TAKE THE LEAD IN
ALL OF THIS.
WE ASKED WHAT HAPPENED TO
DR. BIRX, WHICH SHE STILL BE
AROUND?
THE PRESIDENT PROMISED THAT SHE
IS PROBABLY THE MOST VALUABLE
MEMBER OF THE TEAM AND SHE WILL
CONTINUE TO PLAY A ROLE IN GOING
AHEAD AND FIGHTING THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THIS ALL COMING, BILL, AS NEW
PROJECTIONS SHOW THAT THE
DECLINE IN INFECTIONS AND THE
DECLINE IN DEATHS ISN’T AS QUICK
AS IT HAD BELIEVED TO BE EARLIER
AND THAT THIS MAY DRAG OUT
THROUGH THE ENTIRE SUMMER.
>> Bill: JOHN, ALSO THERE
SOMETHING CROSSING NOW, BUT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO APPARENTLY
SAID THERE WAS SOME SORT OF
THREAT ABOUT
HYDROXYCHOLOROQUINE.
THERE WAS SOME ADVICE TO USE IT.
OTHERS SAID NOT SO FAST.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ABOUT THAT
RIGHT NOW?
>> THIS IS THE FORMER DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR HHS, HE WAS IN
CHARGE OF SOMETHING CALLED BARTA
BARTA.
HE WAS BASICALLY THE HEAD OF
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT AT HHS.
HE CONDEMNED THAT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT WAS
JUST FILED AND JUST LEFT THE
CONFERENCE CALL ABOUT IT AND
TALK TO EVERYONE ABOUT IT.
HE ALLEGES THAT A COMPLAINT THAT
HE WAS TRANSFERRED FROM HIS VERY
PROMINENT POSITION AS THE HEAD
OF BARDA OVER A LESS PROMINENT
POSITION BECAUSE HE WAS AT ODDS
WITH THE PROGRAM THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS PUSHING AND THAT
WAS TO DEVELOP
HYDROXYCHOLOROQUINE IN
TREATMENTS FOR CORONAVIRUS,
WHERE HE THOUGHT THAT THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WERE
BEING THROWN WERE TO WHAT HE
CALLED "PROVEN MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY AND PHARMACEUTICALS."
HE IS ALSO ALLEGING IN THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT THAT
HHS WAS IGNORING THINGS WITH
SOLID SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE BEHIND
THEM AND ENGAGING IN WHAT HE
SAID WAS CRONYISM AMONG PEOPLE
WHO WERE POLITICALLY CONNECTED.
THEY ARE JUST GETTING TO THAT
PART OF THE COMPLAINT IN THE
CONFERENCE CALL.
WE WILL LISTEN TO MORE OF IT.